Ahmed manasra was just 13 when he was
arrested in
2015 he was interrogated and later
placed in a solitary confinement for 2
years it took its store he ended up in a
mental health unit at ayon
prison Ahmed is now 21 and remains in an
Israeli prison he's one of hundreds of
Palestinians whose childhoods have been
stolen through Decades of occupation
some have been subjected to sexual
violence according to the international
NGO save the
children Sala was detained when she was
only 12 a settler accused her of
carrying a knife she was later released
without charges but many others remain
behind
bars there are currently 62 female
Palestinians in Israeli prisons sh is
serving a 16-year prison sentence for
her alleged role in an attempted
stabbing attack her mother is hoping
she'll be released on
Friday since the beginning I was between
yes impossible or possible that there
could be a deal because the situation
was really bad but when I started to
hear that they are serious and I heard
countries got involved to get the deal
done thank God I said there will be a
deal and it's happening
since October 7th more than 20 women
have been arrested by Israel in the
occupied West Bank among them writers
singers and former
detainees Ali Hashim Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer